oh wow it's a cool opponent yeah hi guys
welcome to this video i'm playing daniel
friedman that some one of Germany's top
players and a former teammate of mine
we've played a couple of years and the
same team in the John Bundesliga form
below let's see what he what he's up to
it's not one of his normal openings
let's say he's a default player but he
usually doesn't go for the news o Queen
d3n tend to forget the theory even
though I should know should know stuff I
think Bishop d2 is actually the more
critical move here I think I'm quite all
right I mean like it's also right after
Bishop d to it this is I think less of
an issue now White has this very big paw
information so it's something that I can
play against I wonder if castles was
correct to be honest because now d 6
there might be c5 okay um Queen to c7
night beehive is that an issue I don't
think so this looks a bit shaky but I
don't think he can do something with it
clearly here we have a huge imbalance of
structure against them dynamism White
has excellent pieces bishop on g2 bishop
on f4 knight on d4 all those pieces are
super active but his pawn structure is
basically a gas terrible
with those two coupons so it's um it
just depends who's i'm going to ya uses
some assets better okay like a d6 as an
idea now just trying to takes you form
and it can hardly be a bad mouth all
right you can buy you bet it looks kind
of okay yeah 95 is interesting here if
he can do sir okay if you can do that
not be five Quincy for does this kind of
thing it might even be a theoretical
position but it's been a while since I
wrote the book and I'm not regularly um
rechecking the things okay um well a six
is something I can also maybe just takes
you four why Cannot just takes you four
nine to be five Quincy five what's the
deal how why can I not take this
I don't see it Daniel is a very strong
blitz player by the way he's actually
it's better in Blitzer then in in
regular tournament chess yeah this is
this i saw that but I thought the five
should be okay now maybe I'm wrong and
d5 there is 97 hmm well maybe I can also
go Knight a5 here just attacked us and
take the Queen write a five probably
queen 85 hmm now that's not that great I
would like to play D 5 D 597 cannot go e
5 unfortunately yeah 97 is possible
hmm okay 97 ok I can try to give the
exchange of course this is not totally
stupid the thing is he will have evo at
the end well ok I've wasted too much
time here should affirm decided on that
earlier
yeah well not 97 what else is there
before maybe or something like that not
before I probably have vision to have
sex so here I was just thinking I'm
giving the giving the exchange why not i
but Bishop d7 he can actually take be 70
that's an oversight on my part okay
Bishop f6 is a move just trying to take
stuff myself you should have seen
underneath then you will take them okay
okay maybe i can i can click bishop c6f
it takes on b7 bishop c6 i have half
bishop f6 ideas time morning
I was thinking this is this isn't so bad
but maybe it is I rooks afore maybe hmm
this kind of stuff no okay and now e5
what's the deal here e5 maybe it takes
takes d5 possible I've given up on a
couple of pounds em now it's quite quite
a number of points which is not so great
okay don't want to take him no I wanted
to go g6 actually and okay I was a mouse
slip g6 is far more logical
going for my g4 here okay okay we've got
a little bit of counter play maybe not
enough but I don't know he'd how does it
cover all that stuff he won not G for
coming each was hanging I've got 16
seconds this is probably I mean okay
position is probably not great but the
time is is more of an issue I wants to
take on fa down that's a nice one check
yeah g6 them this is damn Mouse lib
makes a huge difference look for fits on
time yeah no it's a draw actually I've
got enough counter play right okay at
the time um yeah a tough game tough game
then I've wasted too much time him
definitely so yeah what'swhat's
happening here Knight a5 is good for
black am I wasn't sure I really wasn't
sure about all this it's also a good
question if I want to take on see form
immediately or play a six or something
like that I mean I think this position
is ok for me but I think taking us by
far the most principled move so d5 is
actually good
and now g5 gives me an advantage yeah I
don't know I was not ready for some some
good calculation here it seems this is
playable according to the computer and
okay i don't think i mean this this was
a stupid mind of a mouse lee but
whatever i wanted to play g6 in this
position it is making far more sense to
play g6 here because he has a light
squared Bishop I just say it's easier
for him here to cover age seven if you
imagine at age six yeah this is a
typical thing that you can use in your
own games if the if you want to decide
between g6 and age 64 making some loot
for the king you should usually play on
the one that is kind of making room on
on the square that cannot be covered if
possible like h7 can be covered for
example by a queen here now or if the
bishop he exists on e4 it covers this as
well but with g6 and king on g7 it isn't
far less likely that there is a piece
covering g7 here so the g6 is the far
more logical way of creating some look
for the king it was no kind of almost a
mouse slepian I mean it's still not that
terrible okay Queen c6f to play this
losses due to due to this I have no
square that just loses a piece ya ya
hear that was a funny funny thing here
forget 48 yeah 95 and here by now this
is this is ok ok knight c6 actually wins
for black I don't understand why I
because of Queenie 125 ok
as a typical computer tactic and very
nice knight c6 is strong yeah it is a it
is a fork it covers against queen of aid
and if he takes it check Jack winning
this so 96 wins many tactics around yeah
he has this idea quinta da idiom this
was my original intention and then grab
here and then I saw this head for its
funny by the way this is made em check
this is what I saw but the engine is
just going here and says it's a draw
that's cool and I don't understand why
Queen a8 to cover the light squares in
93 is still a draw oh it's cool to
exchange was down here but there is this
idea and afterwards hanging at some cool
tactics yeah my main problem was that i
spent shall enjoy erotic amount of time
now here's s assess the situation and
look at this thing it's covered and it's
I've got this Bishop left so g6 is the
far more logical way of creating this
maze yeah I spent far too much time in
this in this position yeah here rookie
one is is a drawer quite funny enough
why exactly I'm threatening Queen f1
mate it's not a bad threat to have if he
tries to escape I'm actually I'm winning
yeah I was just by material here because
the Lucas hanging yeah what why should
do is to check to do this and now
perpetual himself yeah mmm yeah tough
game here against a very strong opponent
okay hope you enjoyed the game thanks
for watching